triple-a says more than 107 million
Americans will pack airports roads and
railways by far the most more than 97
million will travel by car nearly six
and a half million will fly about three
and a half million are going by bus boat
and train Don Dahler is at New York's
LaGuardia Airport Don good morning good
morning I know what you're thinking
there is no place on earth you'd rather
be than LaGuardia Airport on one of the
busiest travel days of the year
crowded in with a few thousand of your
newest best friends here well a lot of
these folks have gotten here early they
wised up from years past so they get
here early get checked in and also it's
been going in waves it's been really
packed at times and then it quiets down
but it's definitely the beginning of the
peak holiday year end travel season
triple-a says that air fares are about
20 percent lower this year than in years
past and of course low airfares means
more crowded airports the travel agency
projects an increase of just over three
percent compared to last year here in
New York the seasonal increase in travel
is matched with a rise in police
presence of course people will see
plenty of state troopers with bomb
sniffing dogs and automatic weapons the
more than 8 million or 6 million excuse
me expected to fly over the next two
weeks could see new security changes
like this new automated screening
equipment it was just rolled out in
Boston and is already in place and a few
other large airports passengers will
also be asked to remove devices larger
than a cell phone from their carry-on
bags that the TSA which this is a line
right here you can see it's moving
pretty well right now it gets backed up
and then moves on the TSA is adding
about 1400 agents at the 50 largest
airports around the country they are
also adding 55 more k-9 teams so you'll
see them sniffing around Gail you are so
right I was thinking god I wish I could
be near gate d1 and Annie's pretzels
near d7 where's the Cinnabon can't walk
by there without we were falling to that
smell
right that's so true you're welcome
Thank You Don thank you very much